dave chappelle
got called a white supremacist the other
day
because of his comments on gender like
how do you square that circle
well the idea is that there are white
people and then there's everybody else
and everybody else is dealing in
intersectional fashion with oppression
and denigration and not being seen at
the hands of whites if you take on
a perspective of
of antipathy towards one of those groups
underneath and even if you belong to one
of those groups you become
in c2 um that's a misuse of that
expression so just scrap it you become
an honorary white person that's what's
going on so dave chappelle
you know with that rangy black english
and it used to be he's standing there
smoking and you know the one of the
blackest men on the planet because of
those things that he's saying about
trans people he becomes a white
supremacist all of that is
play acting everybody knows that doesn't
make any sense and you know he's had a
very black adulthood a very
black-oriented career where he left his
tv show because he was worried about
what it was making white people think
and yet now he's a white supremacist
because he's not on board with the way
everybody thinks about gay people and
trans people and of course is anybody
surprised listening to his whole career
so that's a lot of this is more of that
so now he's becoming a heretic even
though he's black himself and is fully
quote unquote woke because you have to
make him a heretic because you were part
of a religion where it's your job to put
up your fingers like this at people who
say the wrong thing
this won't do
what do you think about cultural
appropriation
i think the concern over that is absurd
i think cultural appropriation is
inappropriate if somebody from on high
ate somebody from below and makes money
off of it that they didn't what's up
that
there's for example if you say that
elvis presley took on the rock and roll
inflections and music and moves and
became a billionaire while the black men
who originated all of that did not have
as much success and some of them labored
in obscurity i can see an argument that
that's cultural appropriation but the
idea that it's cultural appropriation
when white people do things that anybody
else does
as opposed to anybody else who do things
white people do and that's considered
okay that is as if people are looking
for a reason to be angry as if imitation
isn't a form of flattery as if people
living in proximity aren't going to
imitate one another to a certain extent
and as if any of us wouldn't want
america's popular music since about
1890. if cultural appropriation is wrong
there's no ragtime there's no jazz there
are no show tunes there's no rock and
roll there's no porgy and bess there's
no nothing yeah basically our music no
offense but like i don't i don't think
this isn't an insult for your country
but our music here would be euro pop we
would have that shitty music that you
hear if you go to a dance club in
finland that would be what it except the
music from america and yet we're
supposed to call all of this cultural
appropriation and do high fives because
the religion is all about identifying
racism it doesn't make any sense but we
end up having these fruitless debates
over it because of the imperatives of
this religion yeah the power dynamics
and punching up versus punching down
when it comes to cultural appropriation
really just doesn't seem to make sense
to me i remember last year right in the
thick of it it might mean this year uh
when it was st patrick's day on the 17th
of march and someone had highlighted
that there's a potential hypocrisy here
that people are allowed to wear the hats
and say good morning to you and like
pots of gold and stuff like that and
everyone's got a ginger beard on how is
that not cultural appropriation and i
remember this brand tweeted out saying
that's not appropriation it's
appreciation i thought
like this is just lexical brazilian jiu
jitsu here
yes
it is and what it really is supposed to
be about is brown people for the most
part
having a reason to feel aggrieved
and as we've said before there are
reasons why white people would pretend
to buy into it their reasons why brown
people would pretend to buy into this
you're appropriating me whereas you can
see cultural mixture in so many places
such as you know this pot of gold
business and you can think if that's
okay
why not okay for a white person to say
you to man what's the difference who
does it hurt you know it's not as if if
a white person imitates black people
it's taking away
from us you know you took our word
people say but if we keep using it
that's fine and there are 99 other words
that black people use that white people
never pick up what are the contours of
this argument but it's all just for that
purpose of the genuflection thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few months and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace